tonight's open is a christmas carol to
nancy pelosi
a christmas carol of course was written
by charles dickens in it ebenezer
scrooge an elderly man is visited by
ghosts of his past and is confronted
with the mistakes he has made in the
past
you know the one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the question for ebenezer scrooge here
our own nancy pelosi
is whether redemption is even available
to her
the first ghost to visit nancy pelosi is
the ghost of lawlessness in america
nancy as a lead democrat in congress you
could have stopped this but you refused
to do so in fact you say you don't even
understand where this lawlessness comes
from
it's absolutely outrageous you know
obviously it cannot continue
but the fact is that there is an
attitude of uh
lawlessness in our country that springs
from i don't know where
maybe you do
and we cannot have that lawlessness
become the norm
nancy nancy nancy
you don't know where the lawlessness
comes from
it's in your city of san francisco that
was once breathtakingly beautiful where
people don't even want to walk their
dogs because of human feces on the
street because of needles lining this
street and across america people don't
want to get caught up in the crime
that's enveloping every large city run
by democrats
and admit it the only reason you even
mention lawlessness now
is because you democrats see the polls
the american people are fed up with the
loss of law and order with the rampant
chaos on the streets the unprovoked
assaults the senseless brutal crimes
convicted violent felons led out of jail
long before their release date by
democrat prosecutors and governors
could it be that when the organized
retail theft gang started hitting
high-end stores like louis vuitton it
got too close to home for you and you
felt obliged to say something
you know after all
you are a legislator
the elimination of cash bail under the
guise of social justice has created a
revolving door of criminals walking into
and out of police stations never to
return
you do know that in your precious state
criminals are allowed to steal less than
a thousand dollars repeatedly and not
even be arrested so they repeatedly and
serially hit stores
and then sell the stolen goods on the
streets of san francisco while you look
the other way
yes nancy you helped create the
lawlessness that is destroying my
country
another ghost to visit you nancy is the
ghost of immigration
while we suffer from hordes of
unvaccinated illegals surging into our
country in the middle of a pandemic we
are left to deal with individuals who
are criminals mules for the cartels and
human smugglers our children are dying
from fentanyl sent by china through the
mexican cartels secretly added to
counterfeit pills like xanax that kill
our children in their undeclared war on
americans
gang members come through unquestioned
who go on to maim and kill innocent
americans and what is your answer about
ms-13 and other gang members who carry
out barbaric medieval violence against
innocent victims and when you were asked
about the thugs who maim and kill as
part of their initiation
you say they're all children of god
we believe some of us who are
attracted to the political arena to
government and public service
that
we're all god's children there's a spark
of divinity in every person on earth and
that we all have to
recognize that as we respect the dignity
and worth of every person
and nancy the ghost of greed comes to
visit you
that's a big one for you and your
husband
you've made millions since you've been
in congress and so many of you enter
congress of moderate means and cover
each other's backs so you can all reap
the benefits that ordinary americans
cannot
this week you were advised after a
five-month investigation by business
insider that 49 members of congress and
182 senior congressional staffers
violated the stock act the insider
trading law and your reaction
should members of congress and their
spouses be banned from trading
individual stocks while serving the
congress no we have a responsibility to
report
in the stock
on the stock this is a free market in
people
we have a free market economy they
should be able to participate in that
this brought a huge negative response
from fellow democrats not in congress
this was one of the most disappointing
and maybe to put it even less politely
disgraceful comments uh and and and
views i have heard espoused on this
issue
to put this in context since becoming
speaker of the house in 2018 again
nancy's total assets went from
114 million to 271 million in 2019 to up
to 315 million in 2020
60 minutes even accused your husband
paul of insider trading nancy
and nancy lying to the american public
is another ghost that will haunt you
because as speaker of the house you have
set the tone and the policy for all of
us your lies are too many to identify
but just this week my favorite one is
this one
mr president it is an honor and of
course a pleasure to be here at this
time of challenge and with the
coronavirus financial insecurity for
families national disasters and our
country could not be more
could not be better served than with
this most experienced capable hands than
yours president biden he's just perfect
the timing couldn't be better madam vice
president were inspired by your work for
the people as you continue to be an
invaluable partner to president biden
the president the perfect president the
vice president the perfect partner
nancy the ghosts of christmas past are
all around you
i have no idea how you can change what
has already happened and i have no faith
that greed and selfishness and lies will
even end
but in a christmas carol ebenezer
scrooge learns the errors of his ways
and seeks redemption
i'm not so sure that that is how your
christmas carol ends nancy but hey
it's a christmas season
anything's possible
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else